I feel very Fergie today forget about
trying hi guys my name is grace Helbig
if you did not know now you know your
life is different now
everyone in every dimension of this
existence is playing Pokemon go
so I registered for an account and I
caught one Bulbasaur while laying in bed
and I thought did it I participated I am
so uneducated in the world of Pokemon I
used to play a Pokemon snap with my
brother growing up because I like taking
what I thought were really professional
photos at an extremely amateur level
which should have been huge for
shadowing for my career that I have
currently I played the side games in
Pokemon Stadium with my younger brother
as well like the games that were meant
for the people that didn't know anything
about battling the pokémon battle
stadium was like a blackjack table and
then all the side games were like the
slot machines and I just played the
shove the slots so trigger warning this
video might offend you guys that really
deeply care about specific Pokemon I
thought it'd be really fun today to
review some of the top and most famous
and well-known Pokemon just like we
review red-carpet fashions here on the
it's grace Channel I tweeted out asking
you guys for a legitimate list of the
most popular Pokemon and you sent me a
lot of different lists that have a lot
of different Pokemon on them so I'm just
going to review a smattering of the
Pokemon that are on all of these various
lists yeah what the [ __ ] our chomp GARCH
Garchomp this looks like the most
aggressive color guard leader of all
time Garchomp is clearly a huge Princess
Leia fan loves sharknado Rainbow Brite -
aww seems fun seems like the kind of
person that you invite to your yoga
class Dragonite dragon it looks like
super cute but it's trying to be a
badass right now it looks like the Avril
Lavigne of Pokemon I don't know why but
Dragonite reminds me of
from Mean Girls Rayquaza whoa Hey Girl
hey you look like you just showed up at
your own surprise party and you had no
[ __ ] idea you know like the theme of
the Met Gala this year was fashion in
the age of technology
I feel like this Pokemon is like tremors
in the age of technology also your name
sounds like you're someone that's been
on Jerry Springer get it Rick quaza Evie
oh my god
your Instagram famous right do you have
a very famous Instagram because you
should I'm assuming that that tear shape
on your butt is your tail but it also
kind of looks like you're having
explosive diarrhea in cartoon form
you're kind of like hailey Joe Osmond
and success like that level adorableness
and I'm interested to see what you
become if you take the same trajectory
as hailey you more like you you look
like a sperm okay I see your potential I
think maybe but you also look like one
of those like gummy hand things and you
get in machines in the grocery store
that you can like throw against a wall
cute Mew Mew - oh is this what Mew turns
into okay this is like whoa high school
sperm fit is a mu Wow new Pokemon of
genders or are they all just all neutral
I only ask because Mewtwo seems like it
has tits but I don't know also I like
that your hands look like those plastic
massagers that could massage my back
also do a low ponytail happening all
right lugia or Lu Jia this Pokemon looks
like what most men that watch sports
look like when their team is losing like
oh my god do sports better so that's fun
I like this Pokemon does is constantly
in the come at me bro yoga pose and all
these photos of it that I'm looking up
are just it with its mouth open is it
always yelling is this the
Donald Trump of Pokemon I look a little
bit like toothpaste in bird form but
with me Ganga Ganga has been smoking
weed why did this one make me laugh so
much anger looks like he's so annoying
but you have a beautiful white smile as
that crest white strip oh I get it
gangers one of those people that was
hurt when they were younger and hasn't
dealt with it because their natural
resting face is smiling so even when
they're in pain they're smiling through
it I mean the Joker
for instance you look like grimaces like
cocaine addict cousin superdude
Blastoise whoa a turtle with cannons on
its back now this is the turtle that's
unlike that TLC reality show about
people that prep for the apocalypse
Doomsday Preppers yeah this looks like
the kind of turtle that's on doomsday
preppers where all the other turtles are
like worth we're fine we're cool and
then Blastoise is like I put [ __ ]
cannons in my shell Arceus whoa are
cases like this weird ghost horse that
got caught inside of a drone what's
happening so good for you you look great
Charizard has someone told chars are
that its tail is on fire that seems like
that will be distracting if you got into
battle also Charizard is like the
Channing Tatum of Puff the Magic Dragon
type dragons Charizard greninja greninja
either ran through a field of chewed
bubblegum or has a tongue that is its
scarf also greninja is like a brown
gecko lizard type of thing that's also a
ninja and Thomas car feels like that
would be very cumbersome but greninja
does not skip leg day at the gym
look at those quads and of course
there's Pikachu because yours a lot of
pain behind its eyes to me like this is
a Pokemon that
loves other people so hard because it
just wants to be loved
pikachu seems a little bit like an
aggressive theatre student and then also
like socially awkward eats their
feelings person cat mouse really cute
okay that's it that is my review of some
of the most popular Pokemon you know who
your favorite Pokemon is and how you're
enjoying Pokemon go do I do I want to
know that I want to know your favorite
Pokemon if any of these were your
favorite Pokemon I'm sure you all let me
know who I should have included in this
list and I can't look I I want to catch
them all but and I also don't thanks for
watching guys don't forget if you
enjoyed this video to subscribe to this
youtube channel because we're we're
doing things here making stuff happen
bein relevant talking about pop culture
trends this isn't helping I don't know
alakazam this seems like a very hipster
Pokemon like that handlebar moustache
takes a lot of upkeep is a huge
commitment and also he's wearing
football pads as clothing and holding
two tiny maracas like there's probably
someone in Williamsburg in Brooklyn that
is wearing this exact same thing right
now I get why you're so popular and your
name is alakazam David Blaine must hate
you